if you're like me I can't wait to check
out the movie Strays especially because
it's chock full of some of the funniest
people on the planet Will Ferrell Jamie
Foxx Randall Park Isla Fisher wow and
did I mention that they are all voicing
dogs so I figured I'd take a closer look
to find out what drew them to the movie
and what they thought about the
experience spoiler they didn't find it
rough okay sorry for that let's get into
it I'm imagining Will Ferrell's inbox is
full of like 380 to 500 scripts a day
and that's probably on slow days cause
let's face it everybody wants this
Legend in their film so what made will
choose Strays for starters he kept
getting sent the script from people he
trusted some other people in my world
had read it too and it said this is
really
so curious to see what you think and
then he said he was immediately taken in
by how it fit right in with the Vibes of
those classic Homeward bound-esque
movies about dogs on a journey but also
of course it's
filthy R-rated so when he combined all
of that it made for an intriguing combo
or as will says I remember thinking oh
this could be
this could be really good of course will
is a comedian at heart so he was gonna
need the movie to have a worthy hook and
he definitely got it while you might
assume that the goal for the dogs in the
flick is to get back to their owners and
live happily ever after it's not
um exactly that because the setup is
that Will's character has an owner who
is basically the worst the dog's goal is
to make it back to him to then well
exact some pretty uncomfortable revenge
and while Mr Farrell certainly has a
Keen Eye for comedy he also cops to
being reliant on the opinions of some
decidedly non-entertainment Biz
influences namely his kids according to
will when he pitched the idea to his
kids especially the gruesome and
hilarious Revenge aspect they were very
into it they were like you have to make
that movie The Producers of the flick
Phil Lord and Chris Miller were
convinced in a similar fashion these
guys probably also have an inbox
constantly full of potential projects
and their friend initially told them it
was about toxic relationships they were
like meh that is until the friend
elaborated and he said it's Stars dogs
who bite their owners and we were like
that I understand and of course while
that element of the plot is played for
comedy it does have an underlying
message Will Forte who plays the dog's
horrible owner talked about how he was
happy to play the part if nothing else
to show that people who abuse animals
deserve pain he says that it drives him
crazy to think that people treat their
pets like that he had nothing but
negatives to say about his character
Doug Doug deserved to get his his penis
bitten off the movie might be raunchy
R-rated and hilarious but it also has a
surprising amount of heart and that's
what Drew pretty much all the stars to
It Will Forte said that despite the
hilarity the script really got to him
for what a dirty movie it is I found
myself tearing up in a couple places I
love Fisher who voices the dog Maggie
said she was drawn to the elements of
camaraderie and togetherness them
creating their own family even the
director Josh Greenbaum originally
assumed that the movie would be kind of
a spoof of the classic Disney style dog
movies and he said while that could be
funny he didn't think it was in line
with what he wanted to work on but he
said he was pleasantly surprised by how
much heart and depth the script had he
loved the fact that these weren't
underwritten characters that were just a
send-up of movie dogs these were
actually fully complex fully developed
characters and so that I think is really
what hooked me in he even went so far as
to say the script reminded him of some
classic tearjerkers this reminded me of
films like stand by me and breaking away
and these kind of like where your
friends become your family but even
though it's got heart the movie is still
at its core a raunchy and funny movie
which is what made people like ILO want
to really be a part of it the cherry on
top of the cake is it's just a really
hilarious R-rated movie with an
incredibly and Incredibly rated R
premise Randall Park who voices a dog
named Hunter said he was drawn to the
scope and the scale of the movie because
while it might seem like a silly little
buddy comedy this is very much like an
epic event film about a group of dogs he
feels there's something really exciting
and original about Strays and that the
mix of comedy and heart makes it a
perfect flick to catch in the theaters
it's almost tailor-made to watch with a
bunch of people in a room and to laugh
together and to you know be appalled
together of course it's not just theater
goers who will get to enjoy Strays as
BTS footage shows clearly the cast had
an amazing time making this thing from
the voice actors like Will Ferrell Isla
Fisher Jamie Foxx and Randall Park the
live action cast like Will Forte it's
clear there were a lot of unusable takes
that were ruined because they couldn't
stop laughing and usually that's a
really good sign I mean if Will Ferrell
or Jamie Foxx breaks character because
the script is too funny I am definitely
on board
so clearly a good time was had by all
when making Strays I can only imagine
the same will be true for all of us in
the theaters have any thoughts about the
actors and the making of Strays pop them
in the comments section